so what kind of sources of fuel is there
so this chemical Rockets liquid solid
gas hybrid uh there's electric so what
what are the kinds of fuels we're
talking about what are oxidizes what
what can you just explain your shirt I
guess
yeah the components so uh so really I
mean fuels it's there's kind of two
terms we'll you'll generally hear the
word propellant being used it's anything
that is used to propel a spacecraft or
used in a rocket engine so
um you have to have you know you can
have a fuel here you have to have a fuel
you have to have an oxidizer and you
have to have a spark to actually get
those things burning and that's just a
general law of like the universe you
have to have fuel and oxidizer and a
spark
um now some fuels will by themselves
spark like hypergolic fuels But
ultimately you're always left with some
kind of fuel oxidizer in a spark so um
the the general ones used most often in
Rockets liquid oxygen is kind of the
king of well there's better oxidized but
they're extremely extremely hard to work
with like fluorine
but the generally liquid oxygen so you
just chill oxygen down to its liquid
state minus 183 degrees Celsius so it
can be dense enough to store in tanks
you know it's a thousand times more
dense when it's in a liquid than it is
as a gas
rp1 which is basically kerosene is a
very common fuel
another common fuel nowadays is methane
liquid methane liquid hydrogen is
another it's the most efficient
potential for the most efficient since
it's one of the lightest molecules so I
think uh correct me if I'm wrong but
Falcon 9 uses kerosene and then uh
Starship uses methane yeah because
methane yep for fuel and they both use
liquid oxygen for their oxidized for the
oxidizer okay yep
um but then you know if you get into
hypergolics you'll normally have
nitrogen tetroxide
um which is your oxidizer and some form
of hydrazine
for your fuel
um there's solid rocket propellants like
solid rocket boosters and those are
actually pre-mixed your oxidizer is
inherently like baked literally like
kind of baked into the sludge of of fuel
so like for SpaceX it's all uh chemical
liquid fuels yep yep so how many solid
base uh fuels are there is that are they
still being used today is there most
Rockets yeah and the United States
really is the only ones that well the
only ones I guess early on because it
was really just the Soviet Union versus
the United States the United States
started to use solids pretty early on uh
they're simple and easy but these days
like you know you'll still see them kind
of as traditionally like boosters like
they're used to just uh help get
something off the ground or help give it
a little extra boost so the space
shuttle famously had those two huge
white solid rocket boosters attached to
the orange fuel tank those are solid
rocket repellents
um things like the atlas 5 can have up
to five smaller solid rocket boosters
there's very few rockets that use a Pure
uh at least these days they use a Pure
solid rocket motor for its first stage
um there still are especially in China
there's a lot of startup rocket
companies that kind of use just missile
technology you know they might use like
a they might just be a variant of an
ICBM
um that just use solid rocket fuel
because it is very relatively easy to
develop you know model rockets use solid
rocket Motors and stuff like that so
they're they're still around but they're
just not as elegant and not as uh yeah
not as as used these days